There's one last optimization that I want to mention, and
this is a hardware one. One might expect that the CPU
had to execute all of the store instructions, needed to move
data along the bus from memory to disk, and vice versa.
This would work, but it would be very slow. Instead, streaming
devices, like a disk, have their own controller that is capable
of sending along the bus itself. Through the bus, the CPU
tells it the length of the chunk it's supposed to copy,
the device address on the disk, the memory address, the
command, whether it's a read or a write, and then
tells it to go. The CPU then goes on about
its business while the device controller uses the memory bus
to either read or write the data. Now the CPU
and the device controller are in competition for the use
of the bus here. But because the CPU is going
to find most of its data in the cache, it's not
using the memory bus all that often, leaving it
for the device controller. This phenomenon is sometimes called
cycle stealing as the device controller is able to
steal cycles on the memory bus away from the CPU.